Apple's planning a massive event for
this spring loaded up with new products
just like the spring loaded event back
in 2021 and this is incredible news
because before the brand new report from
Apple leak or Mark Gman we weren't
expecting some of these products until
the summer but now we're getting all of
these in the springtime which is amazing
and according to German's new report
Apple's really trying to reverse a huge
decline in mac and iPad sales which is
why they're going to be giving us
everything out ones with new iPads and
Macs at the same time just a few months
from today the spring launch is going to
include the iPad Air the iPad Pro and
the MacBook Air but there's much more
than meets the eye to this new lineup so
let me explain starting with the new
iPad Air it's expected to come with
basically the same display and design
with the main change being a new chip
now whether that's going to be the M2 or
the M3 is uncertain because we already
have the M3 and apple usually gives the
latest chips to new products but if the
iPad Pro is also coming and we know that
for sure is going to have the M3 Apple
could easily just give it the older M2
to make a huge differentiation between
the two models making it worth spending
a lot more money and if you do save
money with the iPad Air you're not going
to get the best of the best performance
now Apple hasn't updated the air in over
a year and a half and it looks like it's
going to be a 2-year cycle for this new
iPad Air if it gets released in let's
say March or even in April that's over 2
years and the really weird thing is that
Apple usually doesn't release the air
and the pro at the same time so this
would probably be the first time ever
and it makes me think that apple had
some sort of a delay or issue with the
air getting released maybe this past
fall maybe a month or two ago ago but
they didn't but the huge brand new
surprise that Apple's going to give us
this year is that the air is going to
have a new larger size for the first
time ever which is basically going to
match the lineup that we have on the
iPad Pro Models with the smaller one and
the larger one and yes the larger iPad
Air is going to be 12.9 in just like the
iPad Pro which is very important for one
big reason which brings us into the next
product that apple is expected to
release at the spring event which is a
surprise new magic keyboard
to oh wait sorry guys I've been working
on my Spanish recently just kidding
that's actually a new AI translation
tool from our sponsor rasque AI which
allows companies and content creators to
translate their videos into 130 plus
languages to access access diverse
markets around the world with features
like text to voice lip sync and voice
cloning which I used effortlessly with
just one click on rasque AI to do
this Apple's new M3
chip ready to take your content Global
try rasque AI today and unlock a world
of possibilities use promo code Max 20
for a 20% discount on your first
purchase click the link in the
description to try buy it for free today
this new keyboard is going to fit both
sizes of the airs and the pros which is
very convenient for them because they're
maximizing the amount of products that
can support this new magic keyboard
which gets them a lot of money because
these are very expensive now Mark griman
says that this new version is going to
look more like a laptop with a sturdier
aluminum frame compared to the kind of
rubber material one that we have now
that gets very dirty it definitely
doesn't feel that high quality so it
makes me think Apple's going to make
this new one more expensive now there
were a lot of different patents and
features that were leaked with this one
and I think one of the big ones could be
built in Max safe where you literally
have Max safe magnets built into the
back so you can connect it and charge it
with a puck or even do reverse wireless
charging with your iPhone and then it
can kind of reroute that puck through
the SMART connector and charge the iPad
Pro itself and there is a rumor that
there's going to be a clipboard mode at
least a new patent where you can fold it
down and draw on it without having to
take it off which solves one of the
biggest issues that we have with the
current magic keyboard so this new
keyboard is going to be very popular on
top of that Mark Gman says that apple is
also going to be releasing a new Apple
pencil 3 with all of these new products
in the spring and that could feature a
new design design which could be
potentially shorter or have new features
and buttons or whatever else Apple can
think of so I'm really excited and I
really wish they would make a black
Matte Black Version and now let's move
on to the iPad Pro and this is going to
be a big one they're going to be
upgrading the displays just a little bit
to the choice of 11 in or 13 in which to
me means that the size is going to stay
the same but the best are going to get
thinner which could be challenging
because they have the camera there with
face ID built in but I have a feeling
that Apple might give a landscape camera
to this new iPad Pro by giving it the
dynamic Island kind of moving it inwards
into the display and then that way the
bezels can get thinner and they can
still fit the Magic Pencil 3 charger
right above that whole lineup of cameras
and sensors that's going to be very
interesting but the biggest feature on
the new iPad Pro is going to be the
brand new super expensive dual pane OLED
display which is going to be insane it's
going to come to both of the sizes and
it's basically going to have two OLED
panels stacked together which gives you
all of the benefits of OLED like the
crazy contrast ratios the really good
colors and you also get the brightness
it's probably going to have the same
brightness as we have right now or maybe
even brighter with that crazy mini LED
display that we have now but that one
suffers from the Halo kind of glowing
effect well the new displays will not
have that issue they're going to be so
incredibly good the best displays on any
tablet or laptop ever made now as for
the chip of course we're getting the M3
chip and as we've seen with the new M3
MacBook Pros it's really really powerful
so hopefully we don't have any kind of
thermal throttling or basically
overheating because we know the iPad Pro
does not have a fan and with the new
iPad Pro we are expecting a brand new
redesign I'm not exactly sure what
that's going to look like now we did
have some leaks of Max safe coming in
the past but those have died down so it
seems like that might not be coming at
all but either way many people are
expecting this new iPad Pro to be
extremely expensive so get your wallet
it's ready and now finally let's move on
to the new M3 MacBook airs which of
course are going to be packed with the
same M3 chip which makes me a little bit
worried because the new M3 chip does get
pretty hot even in the M3 MacBook Pro
with the fans ramping up as well so I
have a good feeling that we're going to
see significant thermal throttling in
these thin chassis that are fanless so
if you're waiting for that and you care
a lot about performance perance it might
be worth just buying a new M3 MacBook
Pro right now for that extra performance
with the cooling now the cool thing is
that we should be expecting both 13 and
15in sizes at the same time thankfully
they're not going to split it up like
they did last summer it's going to
happen at the same time and I think it's
going to be a pretty awesome new product
as far as features I'm not expecting
anything new I think the Design's going
to stay the same but keep in mind that
throttled performance with the M3 chip
hopefully you enjoyed this video and if
you're not subscribed definitely do it
above and check out one of those two
videos right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video